the loser of this game yes has to eat
these hot wings that are coming out oh
wait what's up everybody it's your boy
Beach and I'm in Chicago tonight I've
been hanging with my man Colin any
chance
we're gonna bowl a few games and we're
gonna play NBA 2k on Google's new gaming
platform Stadium where you can game
anywhere any time
let's go meet up with cat what our bro
what's up cat thanks coming to bowl with
me absolutely
here's your controller which one that
one yes sir okay already plugged in the
chromecast they got Wi-Fi so we're good
to go
oh we let ya bro before we get to the
lanes let's play some 2k and then I'm
gonna beat you listen to each other a
lot that blows here what team you know
is what the cameras around I guess I'll
big minute she's gonna pick yourself hi
can you change when we change uniforms
yeah hey why okay yeah all right let's
get it
you still rocking the sleep I used to
add an elbow thing when I was like
rocking it to protect it but I think
they do look swag you it Oh God
that's how you started no I thought what
are you usually doing you know on your
days off to unwind Wow usually you know
I like bowling with friends but I always
thought you know just really playing
video games you know golfing just really
doing golf yeah how how does it all the
traveling been trained yeah that's
probably the most challenging thing that
has been for me and then bits just
travels it's nonstop what do you do to
keep up with it hope to god my phone I
don't love these graphics it's crazy
playing right and the greatest thing
about it too you can't go anywhere he's
always got Wi-Fi
I know and this crazy saying you told me
I could just have this and I don't need
anything else it saves a lot of space in
the luggage no
oh my god as long as 30 times in the
pretty thought possibilities with what's
like the one thing that I guess you were
kind of skeptical about stadia that you
see is you know this is the real deal
this is a graphics more I feel like it
wasn't one of the graphics because I
mean like my gaming experience what PC
but I didn't know like couldn't really
pull it all yeah there's nothing like it
really does I'm the guy who's been
playing console controller for years so
just to see like the controller itself
is actually very nice to have I mean I'm
gonna show you some crazier things I
have to be finished bowling but G sauce
him up but this is really just beginning
it thank you
both tips with me
go straight got a challenge for you
thanks person think it's a straight
isn't where a loser has to finish the
Hat
[Music]
[Music]
SiC say I just do this sexy as dr.
Willie what happened to 32 I can't see
32 oh you know if I got the ball now you
got the ball now you got the ball you
had the ball your net your new backcourt
dope I say I set up a screen just shot a
full course you didn't set up a right
now but you got a defender on you pass
jumper babe
miss miss announcing is just amazing
just slave all right cat let's hit pause
on this man I'm getting a little hungry
but let's pick the game up at the bar
pixel here for you yeah we're gonna
connect it right here you can take this
one plug it in man pick it up right
where we left off this is actually
ridiculous this is the most impressive
thing because the graphics are just as
good still what exactly that's the thing
that really gets me I'm essentially
still on cause oh yeah all right got one
last challenge feed okay the loser of
this game yes has to eat these hot wings
that are coming out I'm with it do you
have any big goals before them the
season anything else try tapas or just
things you want to accomplish in the
next couple years
oh no I'm gonna see where life takes me
I'm not really worried about the future
yet because I don't worry about the
president to set it up you know that's
absolutely true you know sorry I've been
confirmed bucket I'm a confirmed
that's how you was a confirmed bucket
that man that man that man where the
wings up there is this hot with an H a
WT or a chhoti hot spicy and cool
there's one of them that hit you late
yo I appreciate you coming out with me
bowling a little bit playing some suit
King wizard to get your own yeah go to
stay calm
get your stadium premier edition all
right all right last my G yes sir good
luck appreciate you man but there's more
waiting source it's beautiful finish
[Applause]